[Music]
the voice of an angel but seriously only
in LA can you go to church and see
Justin Beiber hop on stage to sing that
happened Wednesday night at church home
the Biebs singing a little worship tune
and it really shouldn't be that
surprising Justin's always been super
open about his faith if there's so many
bad things happening in the world right
now and a lot of it out of our control
and I don't think it's the time I blame
God for it you know we understand that
there's this free will and people make
dumb decisions and it's not God's fault
so let's just lean on God and trust that
you know oh all we can do is trust in
him I believe it's not my job to push
anything that I believe on anyone else
you know I think it's just my job to be
a light and share what I've been what
I've went through as far as my spiritual
my spiritual journey earlier this month
he even posted a video from Sunday
service what you are seeing is the video
also just made me miss Justin's voice
but we do know he's working on new music
earlier this week he tweeted this quote
late night studio no word on when we'll
get the new music but hopefully soon
fingers crossed
now earlier Wednesday Justin's wife
Haley posted these hanging with her new
adoptive kitten named sue she so cute
and she also shared these new shots from
her Vogue Paris shoot on this pic she
reveals she was inspired by none other
then Princess Diana quote all credit and
inspo to the amazingly beautiful and
iconic ly stylish Princess Diana who
I've looked to for style inspiration for
as long as I can remember
thank you for leaving behind such an
iconic fashion and style legacy and
check out this side-by-side
Haley totally nailed it but back to
Justin how excited are you for new music
what do you think it'll sound like let
me know and for all the latest on the
Biebs keep it locked to all things et
until next time I'm Katie Krause and bye
for now